georges puce mano beach présidents de
républiques souveraines à georges le
cusm à norwich merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors jamais un tel
montant n'avait été atteint c'est la
conséquence de la période inédite que la
france traverse pour soi oui
effectivement c'est un starco c'est un
temps record absolu et c'est
catastrophique pour l'avenir de la
france
il faut quand même rappeler que en état
normal du financement de l'union
européenne la france et contributeur net
chaque année de 6 à 7 milliards
cela veut dire que chaque année nous
avons nous avons une perte qui est
important donc de 6 à 7 milliards
d'euros qui vont à l'union européenne et
qui servent principalement à financer la
réorganisation industrielle et la
réorganisation agricoles des pays de
l'est qui se livre avec la france à une
concurrence tout à fait déloyal
puisqu'il ya aucun protectionnisme au
sein de l'union européenne que les
salaires sont inégaux que les impôts
sont inégaux et que c'est la cause
principale des délocalisations
d'entreprises est une des causes
principales des problèmes que
rencontrent nos agriculteurs donc ce
problème qui était déjà là avant va être
accru de 25% dans une situation assez
grave
alors que nous sommes dans un contexte
de crise inédite
comme l'a dit plusieurs fois par exemple
des économistes comme jacques sapir où
on va être dans des situations qui vont
être de l'ordre de celle de la crise
des années 30 donc on va avoir en plus
des chômeurs donc dans ce contexte là ce
gouvernement trouve que la meilleure des
choses à faire c'est de tenir
l'union européenne à bout de bras sur le
dos des français c'est une véritable
catastrophe et le brave type locaux
vides de crise qui explique à elle seule
ce montant non c'est pas c'est pas les
seuls vous savez qu'il ya un emprunt qui
a été fait récemment vous l'avez dit
rapidement dans votre court reportage
il ya des pays qui sont dits frugaux et
qui eux ont une élite politique qui a
négocié pour signer ce plan de relance
européen qui a négocié des rabais à leur
contribution à l'union européenne donc
que ils sont plus malins que nous nous
augmentons notre contribution à l'union
européenne alors que les pays qui vont
économiquement très bien comme les pays
bas vont avoir des rabais de l'ordre de
700 millions et 700 millions seront
couverts par la france quand on dit pays
frigo ça sonne bien ce que ça fait ça
fait des gens sérieux qui font attention
en temps de crise ça fait un peu
fourmies dans le compte de la de la
fontaine de la fourmi et la cigale
mais en réalité ces pays frigo je
souhaite le rappeler encore une fois ici
il faut le faire à chaque fois sont des
pays qui profitent des règles
inacceptable sein de l'union européenne
qui font du dumping fiscal et qui font
que parce que ils ont des dispositifs
des dispositions légales fiscales
inférieures
enfin moins contraignante que celle de
la france beaucoup de nos entreprises
s'installent là bas donc on est perdant
sur tous les plans ce sont des gens qui
attirent les sièges sociaux des
entreprises comme l'irlande par exemple
luxembourg pour y recevoir des impôts
qui ne sont plus payés en france grâce à
cela ils sont appelés pays frugaux ils
payent moins de contribution à l'union
européenne et nous on va en payer plus
alors que nous perdons des entreprises
qui pourraient payer des impôts en
france
on est réellement chez chez les fous et
mais du point de vue des manuels marron
le président de la république française
il suit la politique qu'il a voulu
depuis les deux pays depuis le début
depuis le début de son mandat
présidentiel
c'est renforcer la souveraineté
européenne sa taille à transférer la
souveraineté de la france encore plus
que déjà été faite à cette instance
supranationale qu'élu européenne et tant
pis si ça coûte aux français et du coup
dans ce contexte le plan de relance
européen est ce que c'est la meilleure
chance pour la france pour sortir de
cette crise alors vous avez raison de
mentionner ce point là puisque deux
aspects ont servi à faire passer la
pilule si on peut dire qu'il ne passera
pas le premier c'est que ça a permis de
sauver la pac
bon il faut savoir que ici deux ans la
france sera également contributeurs nets
à l'impact que nous ne gagnerons plus
d'argent pour nos agriculteurs mais nous
en perdons l'autre l'autre argument
utilisé également par la soi-disant
opposition du parti socialiste c'est que
nous avons obtenu 40 milliards dans ce
plan de relance mais c'est une farce
complète alors je vais technique mais
j'ai essayé de faire extrêmement simple
la france le tout ça a été le
remboursement de cette dette se fera
après 2027
or la france est en continu contribution
le budget de la france à l'union
européenne étant de 17%
cela veut dire que nous allons
rembourser la france donc les français
rien d'évident vont rembourser 66
milliards de cet emprunt de relance or
nous avons nous allons recevoir 40
milliards
un enfant de primaire pourra faire la
soustraction
ça veut dire que la france va perdre en
moins de dizaines d'années quelques 26
milliards minimum donc c'est un
sacrifice colossal que concède le
gouvernement à la sauvegarde d'une union
européenne qui n'oeuvrent pas dans
l'intérêt des peuples clients
particuliers dans dans l'intérêt du
peuple français
donc si ce sont de faux arguments qui
sont très facilement démonter par voilà
par la réalité pareil et les faits et
monsieur macro
reporte reporte le ce problème là à
celui qui sera élu c'est bien
éventuellement après son éventuelle
réélection au delà de 2027
alors jean luc mélenchon dit jamais nous
n'avons donné autant et jamais nous
n'aurons reçu aussi peu c'est un bon
résumé finalement pour vous oui jamais
n'ont donné autant c'est clair et net
c'est ce que je viens de dire c'est ce
que c'est ce que disent toutes toutes
les personnes sérieuses qui venaient ces
chiffres et peut-être pas immédiatement
mais nous avons payé un max et quand je
dis nous c'est françaises et français
qui sont un exemple est encore une fois
on va se retrouver à payer énormément
dans un contexte où d'ici un an et demi
nous aurons à cause la crise du comité
19 et à cause gestion calamiteuse de ce
gouvernement
nous aurons deux millions de chômeurs
supplémentaires des dizaines de milliers
d'entreprises qui vont fermer
donc il va falloir prélever des impôts
sur des gens qui sont des français qui
seront dans une situation extrêmement
difficile
je pense que ça va créer énormément de
stabilité politique dans notre pays
merci beaucoup georges cusma novice je
rappelle que vous êtes président de la
république souveraine